من يفكر بانقاص وزنه فبالتاكيد صادفه
الحديث عن هذا الدواء اوزنبك منتج طبي
مخصص لمرضى السكري شهد اقبالا جنونيا بحثا
عن التنحيف ما ادى الى فقدانه من الاسواق
واثاره قلق الاطباء
للدواء السحري بدائل كدواء مونجارو مثلا
لكن البديل الذي يثير اكبر ضجه الان هو
البديل الطبيعي الارخص والمتاح بسهوله في
الصيدليات وهو البربرين او المعروف بنيتشر
اوزنبك هكذا يقول الاطباء
البربرين يعتبره الباحثون مساعدا مكملا
لعلاج حالات مثل تعديل ضغط الدم ومقاومه
الانسولين وتنظيم الكوليسترول فهو مركب
كيميائي مستخرج من نباتات مثل خاتم الذهب
والبربريس عاده يباعك مكمل غذائي في
كبسولات مليئه بمسحوق اصفر اللون
تم استخدام المركب في اسيا منذ اكثر من
2000 سنه وصار علاجا للشكاوى والمعديه
والمعويه وبحسب تاكيدات الخبراء فانه قادر
بالفعل على انقاص الوزن لا بل انه يحقق
نتائج اكثر ضمانا من اوزمبك الذي لا تزال
فعاليته مسار جدل وكونه منتجا فعالا بحسب
الاطباء فهذا لا يغني عن بعض الاثار
الجانبيه الموثقه كالغثيان وارتفاع ضغط
الدم وارتعاش اليدين والقدمين بالاضافه
لتقلصات في الرحم لدى الحوامل
البربروين بشكل عام مركب امن هكذا تشير
الدراسات لكن الخوف هو من تسويقه دون
ضوابط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات